[Music]
after a week blocking one of the world's
busiest shipping lanes
the ever given is finally free 10 tugs
put it out of the bank
and into deeper water seven days the
world has been watching
captivated as the rescue operation has
gone on
to free the ever given it is now free
and it's sailing under its own steam
and in open water the breakthrough came
in the early hours of monday morning
tugs pulled the ship in four different
directions and it started to come free
by first light it had visibly shifted
but the bow
remained stubbornly wedged as the rescue
teams waited for another high tide
strong currents and high winds worked
against them twisting the ship
at right angles at the suez marine
training center on the banks of the
canal
the officer in charge of pilot training
described what they were trying to do
is
and the two tags pulling this side
in another side of the ship there is two
tanks more
pulling to the
by late afternoon the ever given was
moving slowly north it is now in the
wider bitter lake section of the canal
where it is being inspected for damage
this just shows the
strategic note to the sewers the
fragility of our supply chains i mean
we've got to have some context here this
is a very
rare occurrence with 18 000 transit it's
still the most efficient route to get
from asia to europe but
there's no doubt they'll be looking very
carefully at the the next few weeks
particularly investigation which must
take place now to find out exactly what
went wrong
the sewers canal is open again and the
backlog
will now start to clear it will take
some days though
before shipping along this vital
waterway returns to normal
alisa bundle sky news the sewers canal